[MUSIC PLAYING]
GABRIELA FERRARA:
Hi, and welcome
to Episode Number 163 of the
weekly Google Cloud Platform
Podcast.
I'm Gabriela
Ferrara, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hello, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Gabi,
how are you doing?
GABRIELA FERRARA: I am good.
How is Australia?
MARK MANDEL: Australia is warm.
It's quite nice.
I'm not complaining.
GABRIELA FERRARA: I'm jealous.
MARK MANDEL: It's pretty good.
GABRIELA FERRARA: New
York's quite cold.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, gosh.
Yes, I bet it is.
And I'm very pleased to
announce that my visas have all
been cleared--
[RADIO BREAKS IN] 640s are in.
[INAUDIBLE]
MARK MANDEL: So very
soon I will be let back
into the United States.
GABRIELA FERRARA: So
welcome back soon.
MARK MANDEL: Welcome
back soon, indeed.
So who are we talking to today?
GABRIELA FERRARA:
Today, we are going
to be talking to
Amy Krishnamohan.
She's product marketing manager
for Google Cloud databases.
And today, she's
going to be talking
about cloud sequel for us.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, awesome.
And then speaking of Cloud SQL
and other databasey things,
after our question
of the week, I'm
going to be asking
you about what is
a virtual column in a database.
This is not something
I've heard of before.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Oh,
it's really useful.
I'll bet you're
going to like it.
MARK MANDEL: I'm intrigued.
Before we do all of
that, as per usual,
we have our cool
things of the week.
Gabi, I think you found
some particularly fun stuff.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Yes.
We announced new Google Docs
APIs for process workflows,
making it easier for our
partners and other people
to integrate with Google Docs.
We have links to Zapier,
Netflix and Final Draft.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Yes.
It was presented in Next 2018.
And now it's available
for people to use it.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
GABRIELA FERRARA: And you, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: Speaking of tools
that are available to use,
Jib at 1.0.0 is now
generally available.
So Jib is an open source
project for simplifying
building containers for
your Java applications.
Woo, that was a mouthful.
There's integration
with Skaffold
for Java in Kubernetes.
And it's basically integrated
with Gradle and Maven.
We had a show on
it previously, when
it was sort of around
when it first came out.
That was Episode Number 151,
if you want to check that out.
But if you're
building containers,
and you're using Java, you
might want to check out Jib.
It can simplify your
containerization process
considerably.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Cool.
And this month now, it's
the Black History Month.
Google Earth-- it's making a
guided tour through history
across advocacy, business,
education, and technology,
and everything more related
to the Black History
Month in the US.
It's called the Journey of Us.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
GABRIELA FERRARA:
So check it out.
MARK MANDEL: That's fantastic.
And last, but
definitely not least, I
wanted to make a
mention of a blog series
that one of our fellow
developer advocates, Gabe Weiss,
has been running, called
Cloud IoT Step by Step.
He's on Episode Number Three
right now on his blog series.
Basically, it is
a series looking
at how to connect your
IoT devices to cloud IoT.
He starts really simple and
gets really a little bit more
complicated as he goes.
But we'll have links
in the show notes
if you want to look
at connecting your IoT
devices to the cloud.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Ooh.
I need that-- not
losing my keys anymore.
[RATTLING]
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS]
That sounds great.
Well, I tell you what,
Gabi, why don't we
go have a chat with Amy?
And I can learn new
things about Cloud SQL.
GABRIELA FERRARA: OK.
Let's go.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Today we're going to be talking
about Cloud SQL with Amy
Krishnamohan.
She's Product Marketing
Manager for Google Cloud.
And her area of expertise
is databases, as mine.
Amy, talk to me about what
you do and who you are.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: So yes, hello.
My name is Amy Krishnamohan.
Thanks, Gabi.
And I do product
marketing at Google Cloud.
And my focus is on databases.
So as a product
marketer, we really
try to make sure that
our customer understands
our product and how it is
differentiated in the market.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So I have to admit something.
I haven't touched a relational
database in a really long time,
just because I do weird
things, mostly in game worlds.
But a lot of people do.
So can you give us, like, at a
high level, what is Cloud SQL?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: So Cloud
SQL, in the very simple term,
manages services for
open source databases,
like MySQL and Postgres.
So relational database
has been existent
for almost 30, 40 years.
So I think everybody
kind of knows a lot what
relational database is.
But nowadays, you've seen
the emergence of databases
everywhere.
I think in the DV
engine ranking itself,
there is 250 databases
existing right now.
But interestingly, still,
the relational databases,
like MySQL and Postgres,
is still dominant database
that everyone is using.
So we are providing a
fully managed service
for those open source
databases so that people
can use those database
without really having
a burden of managing them.
GABRIELA FERRARA:
Thank you, Amy.
So beyond Cloud SQL,
what other products
do we support on Google
Cloud for the databases?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: Yes.
So Google Cloud
database actually offer
a wide variety of databases
to serve various needs
that customers have.
So Cloud SQL is focusing
on relational database
for open source database,
like MySQL and Postgres.
And then we also have
a Cloud Memorystore,
which provides a fully managed
service for Redis, free memory
caching.
And then there are also
other interesting databases
are born at Google.
The one is Cloud
Bigtable-- so we call it
as a NoSQL wide column
database services, which powers
a lot of service like YouTube.
And then the Cloud Firestore,
which is document databases.
And it stores a lot of
mobile and web app data.
And it is serverless.
It is very integrated
with Firebase,
so it is extremely easy to
build a mobile application based
on that.
And finally, I think the most
shining star database at Google
is Cloud Spanner.
[NOTIFICATION SOUNDS]
It is a relational database
and globally consistent.
Which is, actually--
I think everybody
thought that it was impossible.
So it's something
that Google made
impossible possible databases.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Yes. it's
that [INAUDIBLE],, right?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: Mhm.
Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
And if people want to hear
about Spanner Episode Number
62 of the Google Cloud
Platform podcast.
I actually would love
to hear just your take
on relational data storage.
I expect there's probably
some of our listeners
who probably grew up maybe just
working on something like Mongo
or are working on
something unstructured.
So I'd love to hear your take on
what is relational data storage
and maybe how has it changed
in the last 30 odd years?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: So relational
databases is really--
the easiest way to
think is, like, table.
So if you look at the sheet,
you have a really clean table
that has a defined
column, defined row,
and the data is
extremely ordered.
So before you
store the data, you
need to know what
data type it is.
Is it going to be number?
Is it going to be text, what
the size is going to be.
So it all needs
to be predefined.
So I would call that
relational databases really,
really structured and
well-managed databases.
So it is mainly used for a
lot of a transactional system,
like financial system or ERP
systems, where you know exactly
what data is going to come in.
So a lot of people these
days are using NoSQL
or unstructured databases.
Those are when you don't know
the data, what kind of data
is coming in.
You can just sort the data
first and then analyze later.
So there are pros and
cons for each databases.
Because relational database
is extremely well-structured,
it is actually much
easier to analyze data.
Because you know exactly
what is in it and then
you can use a SQL
language, which
is actually very easy to learn,
and query those data easily.
Whereas if you're using NoSQL,
or the unstructured database,
like Hadoop, you
really don't know what
data is inside your databases.
So you need to actually
identify and investigate
what data you have
and also build
a kind of custom analytics
to analyze those data.
It has very different use cases.
It is sometimes a
relational database
are just [INAUDIBLE]
for certain use cases.
And then unstructured,
NoSQL databases,
is good for certain use cases.
MARK MANDEL: What
sort of use cases?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: So
a lot of the use cases
that we see like IoT, where
data are just pouring in,
or we have a lot of
social media, or gaming,
they're use cases that our
data is not really structured.
Those are really good for
the Hadoop, NoSQL databases.
And then if the data is
actually extremely important,
like transaction-wise, and then
you cannot lose those data.
For example, if
you are depositing
the money in the bank, you
need that data to be consistent
and stored safely in
certain databases.
So you cannot have, like on
social media, NoSQL database.
So you have to put those data
in the relational databases.
GABRIELA FERRARA: So
how does Cloud SQL
scale inside the
Google Cloud platform?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN:
So Cloud SQL scales
in the two different ways.
First one's a scale out, and
the other one's a scale up.
So scale out is
using read replicas.
When there is a lot
of tactics coming in,
there's a replica
of the Cloud SQL.
You can create it
in different zone.
And you can route those
traffic to the read replica
so that not one
instance doesn't get
bombarded with so many traffic.
So all the traffic can be
routed different, and so on.
And then the other
one, the scaling up,
where we can just
scale the storage,
we have automatic
storage increase feature.
So whenever data is
coming in, our storage
will increase the size
automatically for you.
MARK MANDEL: Can you also scale
up in terms of memory and CPU?
Or is it just storage?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN:
Just the storage.
GABBY FERRARA: Which
is interesting,
because if you're importing
files, like a lot of stuff,
and then, whoa,
your disc is full.
It's like, yeah.
That's not cool.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: Yeah.
We actually have a customer
case where one of our customers
tried to enter all the GIS
information in the Postgres
instance at classical.
And he was using on prem
initially, and after three hour
the job failed.
And then when the
job failed, it means
that everything got
canceled and rolled
back to original state, which
is actually very devastating,
after waiting three hours.
But when they were
using Cloud SQL,
they could see that the storage
was increasing automatically
as a job is progressing.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
Are there any
interesting trade offs
between like scaling
out, scaling up
that people should be aware
of, or people keep in mind
while doing scaling?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: When
you're actually scaling up,
the IOPs size is actually
dependant on the storage size.
So when you actually
provision your instances,
we always recommend to
provision the storage
in a bigger capacity if
you want to get more IOPs.
So when you actually provision
Cloud SQL in our console,
you will be able to see the IOPs
metrics automatically increase
as you assign more storages.
So that is actually a
very important point.
GABBY FERRARA: So all the
features that Cloud SQL has
and the features that
you talked about here,
is there any one
that's especially
for you that you
like, that is more
particular for your liking?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: Yeah.
Actually, one of the features
that I think is very popular
is a high availability feature
that we recently announced
at the Postgres instances.
So classical or Postgres has
a high availability feature,
where we have a
primary instance,
and there is a standby
instance that it is really not
feasible to customers.
But what the standby
instances do,
they always connect with
the primary instance.
And they replicate those
data asynchronously.
So it doesn't really
impact the performance.
It happens really transparently.
So customer will
not notice anything.
And then what we do is we
also do continuous health
monitoring.
So we keep sending a
signal to primary instance
to see if the primary
instance is healthy.
And if we don't
hear anything back,
I think it is about 60
seconds we automatically
switch primary instances
to standby instances.
Failover happens automatically.
So application will not notice
when the system goes down,
because we have standby
instances that are fully backed
up to serve that older traffic.
MARK MANDEL: That's super cool.
That also gives me another
interesting question
around updates of
MySQL or Postgres.
How are those managed?
Cause obviously,
I'm guessing there's
new versions that come out.
And people are going
to want to upgrade.
I'm guessing that's part of
the whole managed service?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: Yes.
So our managed service provides
all the updates, the version
update, OS patch,
and things like that.
So there is a maintenance window
where a customer can choose.
And from that, we provide
all the maintenance.
So there is a little
bit of downtime
while that is happening.
But we take care of all
the updates for you.
GABBY FERRARA: What
kind of features
would you like to see in
the future being implemented
on managed databases.
Not necessarily Cloud SQL, but
managed databases in general,
that you see normal like on prem
have, but on managed databases,
you don't have yet.
So what kind of features
would you like to see there?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: I think
that the most important one
is really having an
integrated experience.
So like streaming data to
the data warehousing system.
So all the transactional data
can go to an analytics platform
very easily, and back and forth.
Or have some sort
of federated query,
where you can query the data
from transaction system, as
well as analytic
system back and forth,
so that people don't
have image about like,
hey, I need to go to this
database to get this data,
or go to the other database
to get this data, having
this kind of data silo.
So really having
universal data platform
access, that will be actually
a really great feature.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds
really interesting.
And I'm curious as well.
We were talking about
unstructured and structured
data.
Are you seeing features
from the unstructured world
kind of creep their way into
the more structured databases
as well?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN:
Yes, definitely.
So I think a lot of
people mention about data
lake becoming a data swamp.
MARK MANDEL: What
does that mean?
Tell us more.
[LAUGHING]
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: Yeah.
A lot of issues that
I think many customers
are having is that they felt
the unstructured database is
really cool because they can
just store the data so easily.
You don't need to
define the table.
You don't need to define
the schema or anything.
But once you try to analyze
it, or [INAUDIBLE] data,
it's becoming really
a big headache.
Either you need to
create a custom code
to decipher all
this data, and then
make sure data is
in the right order.
So a lot of the
unstructured databases
now are trying to implement
the SQL layer on the top
so that people can query
those data easily using
known languages, like SQL.
But I think the
most important thing
is, the reason why I really
like relational databases
is because it's kind of
putting the disciplines first.
So you need to have
a clean data first
if you want to do
a clean analytics.
[SPRAYING]
[CLEANER SQUEAKING ON WINDOWS]
Yeah.
GABBY FERRARA: So hey.
You can not have
data consistency
if you are free to
do whatever you want.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: Exactly.
Yes.
GABBY FERRARA: Although,
relational databases--
and Amy knows probably,
more than I do now--
you can have unstructured data.
We just don't recommend.
Like JSON, or XML even.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: Yes.
Totally.
Yeah.
I think Postgres is actually
one of the best databases
to handle the JSON.
That's what I heard.
Yeah.
So it is not like structured
databases like Postgres cannot
handle the unstructured data.
But yeah.
Still, in my opinion, still
JSON XML is a bistructured.
So it does have a structure,
and it is easy to query.
But when it goes to
really unstructured data,
a lot of tendency for people
is to, OK, we'll analyze later.
Let's just store first.
And I think that is more
about governance or processing
on how to manage your data.
MARK MANDEL: I'm not saying
I've stored XML in a database
before.
But I've stored XML
in a database before.
[CREEPY MUSIC]
[LAUGHING]
GABBY FERRARA: We all
have our sins, Mark.
[LAUGHS]
MARK MANDEL: It was the '90s.
It was fine.
In terms of high
availability, one thing
I don't think we've touched
on is like, how do we
deal with zones and regions?
How do we handle that?
Is that something that's also
managed inside Cloud SQL?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN:
At Cloud SQL, we
provide a zone of
high availability.
So if that one zone fails,
the other will come.
If you are looking for a
more regional or global
high availability, I
really highly recommend
to look into Cloud Spanner.
So in relational databases,
actually the higher
availability and the consistency
is actually a very difficult
problem to solve.
So when you have data in,
let's say, the United States,
and you want to make sure
that the exactly same data is
available in Japan, so we have
to have a consistency of data.
Data has to be replicated
exactly the same way.
Right?
And then the data gets committed
from the multiple places.
Like somebody might store
the data from Japan.
Or somebody might try to insert
data from the United States.
And all those transactions
happen all at the same time.
So in order to make sure that
those data are replicated
consistently, Google really
had made some innovations,
like something like
a true clock, where
we know the exact order
of the transaction.
And then it is really relying
on GPS satellite clock, not
the normal clock
that you are using.
So that consistency
sounds really simple.
But the making
the reality happen
in the relational database
is actually extremely hard.
So high availability
around the globe,
if you want to make that
consistency happen, the Cloud
Spanner, I think it is the
only database that is available
right now.
GABBY FERRARA:
And if people want
to learn a bit more,
where should they go?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: I would
highly recommend going
to Cloud.Google.com website.
It has all the information
about Cloud SQL.
And then our YouTube has a
lot of interesting information
about the classical as well.
So especially if you
search for Cloud Next,
that has a lot of
interesting sessions
that we are covering
about the Cloud SQLs too.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
I'd love to hear more
about your history
with like the database market.
I mean, you mentioned previously
there's over 200 databases now.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: Mhm.
MARK MANDEL: Have
relational databases
changed along with the
innovation that's happening
in the database market?
Or have they stayed
fairly stable?
Or what's happening
there with customers
and the technological
changes to databases?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: So
relational databases
have not been changed a lot.
Actually, if you
see the real history
about MySQL or Postgres, gross
or the enterprise databases,
so SQL Server,
Oracle, [INAUDIBLE],,
they have a heavy
functionality to make sure
that the data transaction
is secured and consistent.
So there's a lot of features.
But the core of the logic
has not changed a lot.
The only change that we
have seen in the last
maybe 5 to 10 years is that
they included functionality
to handle JSON, XML, like
semi structured data.
So they have a BLOB column
where they can insert
those kind of data types.
I feel that the reason
why it's not changing it
is because the core requirements
for using relational databases
is to making sure that the
transaction happens securely.
And then that doesn't change,
whether in the banking system
or health care system.
All the mission critical
systems, that core requirement
doesn't change.
So I don't think that
is going to change much.
GABBY FERRARA: So you told us
what is your favorite Cloud SQL
feature.
What is your favorite
database feature?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: Yeah.
My favorite database
feature is SQL, because it
is very easy to learn.
You can make SQL
extremely complicated.
And I've seen the SQL written
with like 50 lines of code,
which is actually quite crazy.
MARK MANDEL: I've done that.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN:
But my opinion I
think is more straight forward,
that you can learn easily.
And then the power that it has
is actually extremely strong.
And then the skill set
that brings the people,
it is so important.
That's why I think a lot
of unstructured databases
companies are trying to
employ a SQL layer on the top,
because they just need it.
Right?
If you want to scale
your databases,
you'd want everyone to use it.
And if you want
everyone to use it,
you want to make it easy to use.
And I think SQL really
makes that happen.
GABBY FERRARA: I agree.
MARK MANDEL: So what
sort of fun things
can people expect from
Cloud SQL in the future?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN:
For Cloud SQL we
just released the
external master feature
where people can
migrate all from on prem
to cloud very easily with
the just click of a button.
So I think we will
try to really provide
those kind of seamless
experiences more
to the customer.
So whether they're
using on prem or cloud,
it's very easy to
move back and forth.
MARK MANDEL: So I have
one more question,
which is, what is the most
interesting or strange thing
that you've seen someone do
with a relational database?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: The most
interesting that I've seen
is actually using the
relational database
as an analytical database.
There are many companies that
are using MySQL and Postgres
as their analytical databases.
And they're complaining
about the performance.
So My SQL and Postgres is
a transactional database.
It needs to be used
for transactional, not
for analytical.
MARK MANDEL: So how many
records are we talking about?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: Yeah.
They're actually
using a Select Query,
Select All when there's
20 columns in the table
with the millions of rows.
And they're complaining
that they're not
getting the result fast, which
is not the right use case.
GABBY FERRARA: Yeah.
I've filed that plan before.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: Yes.
And it does happen.
MARK MANDEL: So
Amy, before we go,
is there anything we
haven't touched on,
or anything you want
highlight or talk about,
events or anything
cool going on that you
want to make sure that we get
on the podcast before we leave?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: On March 19,
we will be at the PG Conference
at New York.
And we will have
a full day session
on Google Cloud databases.
So that session, if
you come to that,
you will be able to hear
everything about the Cloud
SQL, all the
interesting features,
as well as all the
Google databases.
So we are going to bring a
lot of Google engineers, PMs,
and dev rel, like
Gabby, who are expert
in knowing all databases.
And they're going to talk
about interesting features
of databases there.
GABBY FERRARA: So thank you,
Amy, for coming to our podcast.
It was a pleasure having you
here, and explaining to us
all the cool things about
relational databases.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Thank you so much.
Definitely learned a
whole bunch of new stuff.
It was good.
So we have our
question of the week.
And I get to ask
you fun questions.
Which is really good.
I get to learn more
on new cool things.
So we were talking
before the episode.
You were talking about
virtual columns in a database.
And I was like, what is that?
[DIGITAL BLIPS]
So Gabby, what is a virtual
column in a database?
GABBY FERRARA: So do you know
what a view is on a database?
MARK MANDEL: No.
Tell me.
So let's say I don't.
I have no idea what a view is.
What's a view?
GABBY FERRARA:
Let's say you have
a complicated query that
you execute multiple times.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
GABBY FERRARA: And you create
a view to make it easier
to see the results
of the query that you
execute multiple times.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
GABBY FERRARA: A virtual
column, it's like a view,
but it's inside a table.
So instead of making
complex queries,
let's say you have a
table of products sold,
and you have how many items
are sold and the price.
And you want to know
the total price.
Remember, numbers are tricky.
[LAUGHS]
So making the math on the
Java side, on the PHP side,
on the Python side, to know
the total could be trickier.
So if you have a virtual column
saying, what is the total,
and you can say the total
is the items, the quantity
times the price, then you have
how much it costs as a product.
So you have [INAUDIBLE],,
the single source of truth,
the right value for
your product price.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
GABBY FERRARA: So in the
end, it's quite useful.
Yeah.
And the values are
calculated on the fly.
MARK MANDEL: Oh.
Very, very cool.
Is this supported across
different SQL databases?
Or is this like particular ones?
GABBY FERRARA: So from
the officers databases,
this is mostly
supported by MySQL.
It's not supported by Postgres.
But you can get around with
a view, as I said before.
And off the shelf
databases, there
are couple, like Oracle and SQL
Server that supports it also.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
And I can see we've got stuff
that's going in the show notes
so that people can
check that out too.
GABBY FERRARA: Yep.
Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Awesome.
So what other things are
you doing coming up soon?
Are you going anywhere, writing
anything, doing any fun stuff?
GABBY FERRARA: Well, I
catch a flight to London
to be there, to talk about
[INAUDIBLE] PUK and MySQL 8,
and then Cloud Next in April.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
GABBY FERRARA: And you, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: I will be
at GDC later in March.
I'm actually pretty excited.
I did a little
spotlight interview,
because we're sponsoring GDC.
So if you want to hear
about what Google is up to,
and what Google Cloud
is up to at GDC,
make sure to check that out.
It's got links to
our mailing lists
and some of our announcements.
But we have more stuff coming.
So it's pretty exciting.
But yes.
I'll also be at Cloud Next.
I'll be presenting there.
And later in April I will be
at East Coast Game conferences
talking about all sorts
of other fun stuff.
GABBY FERRARA: And
Agones as I imagine?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Agones, open source.
All the good things.
All my favorite things.
GABBY FERRARA: Good.
Good.
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Gabby, thanks
again for joining me
for yet another
week on the podcast.
GABBY FERRARA: Thank
you for having me here.
Always a pleasure.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
And thank you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
GABBY FERRARA:
See you next week.
Or later.
I don't know.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, and welcome to episode
number 163 of the weekly Google
Cloud plat-- hm.
[WHEEZING]